what's going on uh in terms of sopra
sopra me and will hung out all summer we
had a sopra summer what uh what's going
on there
yeah so soper looks at the profit-taking
uh or i'm sorry the state of profit that
the market is holding on any given day
so you're taking a ratio of all the
coins trading in profit all the coins
trading in loss and you get super and
then here we look at a super which is
adjusting for all the outputs below an
hour
and then we're also
doing a seven-day moving average on this
so we're looking at essentially the
weekly version of soper um and so as you
can see recently that we've just bounced
off one you know obviously that's a good
sign so far but we want to see
obviously an uptrend in the in the ratio
but at least you know at the minimum um
some stabilization above one
um you know in in bearish markets you
fade the the retests of one and then in
a in a bullish trend uh you know in a
broader bullish trend you buy the dips a
long one and so if we are in a broader
bullish trend which i personally believe
we are but
it's up to you for to to decide
um all these re-tests of one will become
you know good off buy opportunities
if if you're correct about that
assumption so
we just bounced off of it you know once
again want to see some stabilization but
preferably you know increase in the
ratio
i definitely think we're in a bull
market i think you do as well so it's
great to see it bouncing off of off that
one tell us what's going on with the
whales we've got this chart that filters
out all of the kind of exchanges and
known entities uh but explain to us
what's going on here with this whale
chart
yeah so this is just looking at all the
entity flows
so the green line we have whales this is
filter out for exchanges grayscale qbtc
uh the purpose etf then we have a couple
different lines here we have the shrimps
the crabs the fish octopus so it's just
saying all these different size cohorts
and so what you see is um the high level
you know takeaway is that every uh
single cohort is accumulating right now
as of the last three weeks when you
started to see
the 100 to 000 btc guys start to buy as
well so right now you have every single
cohort uh accumulating which is which is
pretty remarkable you know when you go
back and uh look at times where you see
all cohorts accumulating in unison uh
that's that's historically you know been
a pretty good time to average and
supplies i don't have a chart of that up
here but i have put that on my twitter
in the past it's happened a couple of
times before
and so you ask you know where are these
coins coming from um and the answer is
exchanges right we keep talking about
how coins are moving off exchanges
in the last week you have
2869 btc moved off exchanges um which is
about
134 million dollars i think i used a 47k
btc price for that
and they're also down 62 251 btc in the
last month which is about 3.2 billion
dollars
and so
this leads us to the next chart um you
know you see that that purple line is
the exchange splash ratio so comparing
all the coins on exchange just to off
blue line we talk about this a lot the
liquid supply ratio you're comparing
the strong hands to the weak hands
essentially so the entities that
statistically sell a lot the entities
that's this
bit rarely sell right
and so we have another bullish
divergence when you you know look at
both ratios in comparison to price price
is kind of bleeding sideways bearish
well i put this out i created this last
night so as of this morning i mean maybe
that's starting to change
and then you know this was the same
thing that happened in the summer we
were tracking so uh that those are the
supply dynamics the one thing i wanted
to i wanted to touch on was just the um
the bids i think this is like important
for people to to keep in mind um it's
the second chart
so what you're looking at here is all
the it's just a heat map of all the biff
and x orders uh the all the bids and
asks on the order book
and so what you see is we have this huge
floor below us
and so
you you can look at this two ways um the
bullish case is obviously like okay the
the chinese bull whales have just set
this concrete floor um and you know you
have started to see started to see some
of those orders filling the other day
but the the perhaps more nuanced view
and i'm not saying this this is the case
i'm just saying keep this in mind um the
bearish case would be that these walls
sometimes are used to generate liquidity
to uh either enter or exit positions so
you can you could set a huge wall of
bids right and then whenever the you
know the retail guys start to see price
you know bleeding down into that wall or
or floor i should say um they're going
to try to front run that because they
see hope there's this huge wall like no
one's going to sell into that so i'm
going to start selling or closing my
shorts above that on the other end
or i'm sorry closing my lungs above that
on the other end you could have that
entity that set the set the floor
actually using that liquidity to exit
the market and then conversely if they
set a giant wall of asks you know it
could be them actually trying to enter
into the market they're basically
putting a cap on the price everyone is
is trying to front run that wall and
sells into that or closes you know
closes their lungs or open shorts uh
like front running that wall and on the
other end of that are actually
the same entities that or entity that
created that wall
or sealing
are actually in in the market you know
getting long so
you you
you know there's there's nuance to it um
but as i mentioned like the other day
you have started to see some of these
these bids fill um going back though
like
biff and x
activity i could say um has has been
pretty influential on the price like you
see them cap price a lot and set the
floor often times
it's just you know keep an eye on it
because if you just see the floor get
rugged then you know that's that's not a
good sign what's up guys bang bang
thanks so much for watching the best
business show today if we're going to be
the best business show we obviously need
the best partner that's why the
exclusive sponsor the best business show
is sofi they're an all-in-one platform
that allows you to invest in all kinds
of different assets including stocks
etfs crypto ipos and they even have an
automated investing function if that's
your thing so before we start getting
after it again make sure that you go
download sofi you get an invest account
and when you make your first crypto
trade regardless of what you buy they'll
give you 10 in bitcoin for free it's
that simple head on over to sofi.com to
get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]